you've got a lot of easy angles you can
really use your calculator and take
advantage of like the fact that it will
do things accurately and quickly for you
so sine 270 degrees someone kick me off
everyone naked one very much okay now by
the way before I go on of course your
calculator to you accurately but there's
another way that you can know right our
old friendly unit circle okay cause
inside are the coordinates of points on
that circumference right which one is
causing which one is so what do when
you've got the X&Y coordinates with my
sign is the wire right so if scientists
70 27 degrees is 0 91 all the way to 270
like that that reflex angle go around so
the Y corner down there is negative 1
because it's the unit circle right so
you've got down by the answers good I
Caleb's much the restive cause my knee
is your car lady someone else David 0
very good and again because so does the
y value causes the x value where's 90
degrees it's come all the way up to the
top there's that 90 degree angle there
and of course the x value up here is 0
right so you get that let's run through
a bit more quickly someone hasn't said
anything yet 10 180 0 side 225 now can
we get it as an exact value I'm always
giving you you might have seen you're
saying to get a sense right I'm giving
you these at the beginning because these
exactly is so useful to get your back
pocket and be able to learn them right
so we don't need to do decimals so do
yes 1 over 2 minus 1 over 2 oh good okay
I cause 330 who's got somebody had said
even yet he's got cos 3 many route 303
302 okay ah which would get suspicious
in a second now when you have a look at
five six or seven we've got questions
that turn around the other way and we
looked at these on Tuesday its then I'll
sign of something and then you give me
the egg the answer right I already
giving you the answer and I want to find
out what the angle is ok so sine x
equals 1 over root 2 now what would be
your first step to solve this sorry okay
you want to get rid of side of this side
right so you got to go poppy catheter
sine inverse of 102 you might recognize
102 it should hand you back with 45
degrees okay so x equals 45 degrees that
is a solution but we know it's not the
only hood right there's another one what
what's the other one it's going to be
180 take away that angle right if you
remember when we had that graph of sine
X okay when you put your 10 rue to line
through it it'll connect twice 145 at
once at 135 and you can pop it in your
calculator and verify should get that
single time okay sine x equals 0 again
if you like you can put inside of us and
give you the first answer which is your
0 okay but this one's a bit sneaky right
you could get the other etta the same
way you get another answer rather the
same way we got this one right see how
this is 45 and that's really 180 take 45
right that's why we get 135 from right
you can do exactly the same thing here
so if I got zero but all the other angle
be willing it will just be 180 take away
0 which is 180 but come in wonder there
is one more steal third awesome which is
360 right because remember this is all
the unit circle right if zero is an
answer then going all the way around 360
is exactly the same as 0 because 0 CR
and 360 years surprise surprise at
exactly the same spot okay so great
that's a bit of a tricky one three
answers